yes you're honorable
thank you
hello everyone uh my name is mohit
mazumdar and i am a bioinformatician by
education and since last 12 years i have
been practicing and applying
bioinformatics for research and now both
for student driven research projects and
academic and industrial collaborations
so during my phd i learned to apply
machine learning algorithms to variety
of sequence based data sets and we're
able to design and complete several
research projects that are now published
in peer-reviewed journals
so with this
incredible growth
i think big data has turned out to be a
remarkable career choice for many today
industries from various domain offered
different positions for big data
professionals that includes biology and
healthcare too so some of the topics
that we are covering in this
in this program are quite relevant to
the industry
so
from a data perspective i think we have
already heard from elia a lot about it
so what i think is what makes biology
unique from other realm it
is its sheer size
so i i think that for example like for
example if i have to give you an example
a typical genome of a microbe which
might have 4000 genes and if we assume
that there are like
1000 meaningful distinct variants for
each gene then that's like almost 1
billion samples to test so i mean if you
if you consider that sort of uh
volume of data it's just really really
very big
so uh genomic researchers they utilize
biometrics to speed up
related to analyzing dna sequences
ultimately helping inform teams looking
to combat the given disease so kubit
vaccines and cancer research are two
areas of genomics that is greatly helped
by bioinformatician and bioinformatics
similarly in the case of drugs
as vaccines and future cancer treatments
current pharmaceuticals can also become
more efficient and they are moving in
the rates in that direction with almost
instant analyzation capability afforded
by bioinformatics right
and machine learning
machine learning helps to make databases
more searchable and trackable by
biologists whose human understanding and
instinct are paired with power of ai and
that power of ai can create a kind of an
investigative ecosystem so that's
something that we all are looking
forward to
about this program i think
our team
and industry within our team and with
our industry and academic collaborators
contributing and developing this unique
program that takes you through the omics
logic learning experience and provide
hands-on training through the powerful
ebay info platform
so uh let me tell you about the intended
outcomes and some of the learning
objectives of the program so some of the
things that we will be doing is that we
will be learning about the terminologies
for machine learning and artificial
intelligence in biomedical
discovery
we will be understanding the analytical
methods for processing visualizing and
analysis of complex biomedical data
we will be understanding the machine
learning taxonomy and also the commonly
used machine learning algorithms which
are used to analyze different kind of
biomedical data
we will have hands-on practice
in application of standard unsupervised
and supervised machine learning methods
to various types of data such as
genomics transcriptomic metagenomics
imaging data and clinical data
you will be becoming familiar with
project example where machine learning
was used effect effectively to achieve
meaningful results
and then you will be able to understand
differences between machine learning
categories
i mean categories of algorithms and
different machine learning algorithms in
different categories
which would be like what kind of data
sets they are good for
and what kind of problems they are good
for and they are applied to and then we
will understand about different
applications of machine learning in the
aspects of project design
uh objectives
and then we will learn about python
packages for data visualization and
analysis of uh and and using analysis
using machine learning methods by python
and then apply machine learning
techniques to analyze public domain data
all in your own data sets so those are
some of the things that are intended to
come out of this program
so
this course
and this program is designed as a
combination of online resources then
there will be practical assignments and
there will be live sessions live
workshops that will be conducted
through zoom and throughout this program
we will review several project examples
that demonstrates the success
or the limitations of conventional
machine learning methods and also deep
learning uh methods using data from
public repositories
okay so now let's uh go to the sessions
that what sessions will be the next so i
would wanted to give you an overview of
what is coming next so in the next
session uh that will be the second
session uh we in this session we will
learn about various omics data that are
generated through high throughput
technology and contains detailed
information for example genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics
and then we will learn about the
overview of approaches and we will learn
from used use cases for various types of
machine learning algorithms for
clustering and classification
to visualize and interpret
multi-dimensional data
the fourth session in this session we
will overcome some of the challenges to
compress complex information into an
interpretable
representation
representation accurately
and in the fifth session and this
session we will learn about the very
critical challenge to organize data
using complex patterns in a space
that is beyond human imagination and we
will be in the multi multi-dimensional
space as i said
and in the sixth session we will be
learning about the application of
supervised machine learning for
classification in this session we will
be learning about uh how do we train or
training an algorithm to find and use
patterns that we think are
meaningful
uh in the seventh session in this
session we will learn about feature
selection and gene signature
construction
and after that in the next session we
will be
using regression and generalized linear
models to understand relationships in
data by finding association between a
pattern and
influence
and then
in the next session which would be the
ninth session and this would be in
november
uh we will be learning about this of
interaction between many players for
example
across tissues uh across time points or
across individuals
so uh after that uh in the 10th session
we will be combining uh machine learning
methods and and we'll be understanding
that how machine learning methods and
with predictive modeling we are going
towards
automation so
we will be learning up from some project
examples uh to
understand how machine learning is
helping in automation
and then in the next session we will be
diving deep into
the
deep learning to make a network a
deep learning approach which is uh we
will learn for classification so there
are different types of deep learning
methods that we will be learning about
and implementation of time series data
and then it would be about the project
so after learning and applying all these
different tools
that are available for
for a data scientist to be applied on
different types of biological data we
will be one we would be working on
with participants to develop a
project or to be able to work on group
projects or ongoing projects so here we
will be discussing about project design
understanding of the used cases for data
analysis
and the need for
you know data structuring
for before you go to the analysis and
while doing this we will be also taking
you through some of the examples and
those examples are from
clinic
so in the clinic
in the clinical condition i'm sorry
let me go back to the previous slide
yes for the clinical condition i think
we would be talking about
biomarkers diagnostics treatment and
also drug repurposing
and after that we would be talking about
the industry
challenges so we'll be talking about
palma and biotech companies and their
need for machine learning and data
mining
data mining projects
so overall we will be taking you through
some of the resources and some of the
problems from the 20th century and learn
about the importance of these
technologies in the future
and we will be using um
[Music]
tools such as our and also python to
extract meaningful insights from large
biological data sets learn practice and
achieve biological greatness with
concise exercises and interesting
challenges right in front of in comfort
of your own browser so that is one of
the advantages of this program and to
tell you more about the resources and
and
the data sets and the opportunities i
would like to
invite our community manager
uh mr nalika and i will be happy to take
any questions that you might have
for me
uh so we have a very consistent question
coming up that what about the beginners
uh how will they start with the
languages or let's say data science or
machine learning because there are a lot
many topics which are covered here so
could you please highlight on that
yeah so actually that is being something
that we discussed earlier also so this
this is not just based on the live
sessions but you will have an ac you
will have access to all the asynchronous
courses
and right now sonalika will take you to
the asynchronous process that is
actually built for anyone so anyone from
biologists to clinicians from experts
can learn from those asynchronous
materials so those courses are designed
in a way to make sure that you
go through uh the
content and learn about what we will be
covering sessions too so i think if you
start going through that material which
is available online and you can do it
from actually anywhere i think i think
that would be really helpful for you to
go through the sessions and interact
with our mentors and design a project so
all of this is this is possible when you
start from if you are starting from
scratch and that is from the
asynchronous material on machine
learning on different type of omics data
on different type of application
projects everything is available on
learn or mix logic
and i think snarlica will be able to
show you how you can get started
there
thank you so much sir
if there are any other questions you can
post in the chat box and